so as you guys may or may not know the
reason I'm an American living in England
is because I was recruited here to play
volleyball I play Semi-Pro volleyball in
England
um I now these days I barely go to
practices because I'm just so freaking
busy but I do I do love sports and I
play whenever I get the chance
um so I saw an interview talking about
women's sports let's play it a lot of
people don't watch the women's leagues
do you think it might help if they
played topless no that was extremely
misogynistic and disgusting the ratings
would probably go up right yeah but
that's pretty what do you think's a
better idea to get the ratings up
educate and advocate for women's rights
especially where would the money come
from that's why I'm trying to figure out
revenue streams well you have to spend
money to make well they've definitely
been spending money so no on the topless
thing your women should play naked uh
yes yes yes do you like it yeah I don't
mind it is me too nice dude okay funny
thing notice how he asked a question
they didn't like and they got offended
because the answer
looking as a woman in sports I've said
this if women really wanted to make
money I have no wish to do this I don't
I don't want this to happen but if they
really wanted to make money they'd sell
sex and it's really interesting because
you see the top female athletes doing it
anyway you're gonna you're gonna see the
top women athletes starting only fans
um you saw that woman flash her tits
when she won the UFC whatever in women's
sports
um and and you're gonna see it over and
over again women selling sex because
they can't make money
um so what's my answer to that question
yes it would make women profitable
I would argue that we should do social
media first I think they should make
money on like female influencers somehow
like manage their social media accounts
but then the problem is those
influencers are just gonna start getting
naked I I think you could do like
reality TV around women's sports like I
think the only way you're really gonna
make money is through entertainment or
selling sex
I love women's sports but honestly the
more they whine and about hey I
just say take it away I say I would cut
the whole league if I was a man because
all they do is whine and I I think women
as athletes we should be grateful that
the men allow us to have these leaks but
let me know what you guys think in the
comments make sure you like the video
and subscribe to the channel on your way
out and I'll talk to you next time